نتيجه انتخابات اليوم في تركيا تقابلها
نتائج انتخابات الدوره الاولى البرلمانيه
التي تشكل عاملا مهما في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه فمقاعد الاغلبيه في البرلمان
تمنحه للرئيس صلاحيات دستوريه اكبر
خلال نتائج الجوله الاولى تمكن الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان ممثلا بحزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم والاحزاب المتحالفه معه تمكن من
الحصول على اغلبيه مقاعد البرلمان المؤلفه
من 600 مقعد بواقع اغلبيه
322 مقعدا اما مرشح المعارضه كمالك لتجار
اوبلوم ممثلا باحزاب الطاوله السداسيه فلم
ينل سوى
2003 وثلاثه عشر مقعدا من مقاعد البرلمان
بينما حاز اليسار الاخضر وهو الحزب
الموالي للاكراد على المركز الثالث بواحد
وستين مقعدا في البرلمان وفي ظل اصلاحات
اردوغان اصبح الرئيس الان هو من يختار
ويعينوا الحكومه
ابرز التحالفات الانتخابيه بالبرلمان
التركي
تحالف الجمهور
322 مقعدا تتوزع على حزب العداله والتنميه
ب 267 مقعدا
حزب الحركه القوميه 50 مقعدا
حزب الرفاهه الجديد خمسه مقاعد
الاتحاد الكبير بدون مقاعد
تحالف الامه 213 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب الشعب الجمهوري ب 169 مقعدا
حزب الجيد باربعه واربعين مقعدا
تحالف العمل والحريه 65 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب اليسار الاخضر بواحد وستين
مقعدا وحزب العمال باربعه مقاعد
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام 2018 حيث 295 مقعدا عام 2023
تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حيث 146
مقعدا عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حازت 49
مقعدا عام 2023 حاز 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد
عام 2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44
مقعدا حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاز 67
مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 61 مقعده
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات